jeudi 2 avril 2015 une nouvelle
assemblée départementale est élu 25
femmes et 25 hommes pour six ans de
mandature
après le temps de la réflexion vient
celui de l'action chaque période connaît
son contexte et ses contraintes
d'un côté une baisse de l'accompagnement
législatif et financier dans l'action de
la collectivité et de l'autre cent
cinquante huit mille demandeurs d'emploi
la route pour 2021 doit explorer de
nouvelles pistes de nouveaux leviers
afin de répondre à la demande sociale le
développer l'employabilité et soutenir
les créations d'activités favoriser
l'insertion de nos concitoyens les plus
vulnérables en mobilisant l'ensemble des
ressources de la collectivité et de
notre territoire est un choix ambitieux
un défi pour les six prochaines années
la nouvelle donne des compétences
territoriales doit être perçue comme une
opportunité celle de l'ouverture aux
autres collectivités sans perdre de vue
l'insertion à travers trois grands axes
favoriser le développement humain
innover dans la construction des
parcours d'insertion promouvoir le
développement des territoires
choisir la famille comme pierre
angulaire d'une politique d'action
sociale a du sens à la réunion la
solidarité intra familiale est un atout
pour faire grandir notre jeunesse
ma
quant aux personnes âgées aux porteuses
de handicap elles doivent être
considérées sous un angle sociétal afin
d'éviter l'isolément
une approche qui ambitionne de combiner
sociale et insertion et la découverte
d'activités manuelles comme ici avec le
renforcement des chèques marmaille ou
encore la création de maisons
d'accueillant familiaux par micro région
permettra de rapprocher et d'optimiser
les dispositifs d usage et l'innovation
passera également par une simplification
de l'accès aux aides traduisant ainsi
une démarche d'intelligence
institutionnel le dio sociale et
insertion sera aussi appliquée pour tous
les événements sportifs culturels et
éducatifs
ils doivent être les vecteurs de cette
première politique d'insertion
une modernisation des établissements et
des sites à vocation culturelle pourra
faire de ce patrimoine un atout pour les
réunionnais préparez-vous à visiter
bientôt la route des musées des jardins
la collectivité met tout en oeuvre pour
permettre la scolarisation de 62 mille
collégiens inscrits en 2015 innover les
parcours d'insertion des publics en
difficulté devient donc une nécessité
un réunionnais sur quatre vit dans un
foyer bénéficiaire du rsa
plus d'un jeune sur deux est touché par
le chômage une situation dramatique qui
rend l'enjeu considérable pour notre
collectivité une baisse constante
d'accompagnement financier de l'état et
pourtant le rsa représente toujours 40%
du budget total la collectivité
l'innovation passe par le pilotage des
projets d'insertion et l'accompagnement
des publics par exemple la création de
la spl environnement assertion sera un
outil souple et efficient afin
d'optimiser les parcours des personnes
en contrats aidés contrat d'engagement
réciproque d'utilité sociale formation
aux bénéficiaires du rsa contrat unique
d'insertion marche en contrat à durée
déterminée d'insertion
si les dispositifs d'insertion ne
manqueront pas le déploiement des
maisons départementales optimisera
l'action de la collectivité pour la
concrétisation de tous les parcours
la collectivité est un acteur majeur de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement économique domaine
forestier espaces naturels sensibles
zones agricoles réseau routier ou encore
politique de l'eau la collectivité
garante d'un investissement responsable
équilibrée et durable
un véritable levier économique
préserver les terres agricoles en visant
l'objectif des 50 mille hectares passera
par une modernisation des exploitations
mais aussi satisfaire à long terme les
besoins en eau des territoires autres
aménagements structurants optimiser le
réseau routier foncier et immobilier 90
mille hectares d'espacés naturels 400
sites bâtis 700 km de routes
départementales
ces développements permettront de
booster l'économie et notamment la
cinquième microrégion les eaux des
projets également à l'échelle humaine
comme lakers car vocation économique ou
encore la filière bois de goyavier
donneront une dimension globale aux
aménagements faire face est une
nécessité de cette mandature
les élus ont fait le choix d'une
politique sociale patrimoniale
environnemental économique tournée vers
l'insertion l'épanouissement humain et
le développement territorial
la mutualisation et l'optimisation
deviennent des priorités de la mandature
une priorité pour 2021